ilhan omar claims that
the republicans and conservatives are
trying to subvert democracy
i don't think that's true these terms
things like democracy are very broad
terms so i want to bring it down to
earth for a second
but i will make the broad claim i think
conservatives are much more interested
in defending democracy
than liberals and leftists and
progressives and whatever term you want
to use
and i'll give you an example of this
that i think throws it into stark relief
down in tennessee
there's a new bill in the tennessee
general assembly
that is trying to create a legal
procedure
by which a man can
prohibit a woman from aborting
his child i love this bill i think this
is a great bill
it's sb0494 in tennessee senate
and hb 1079 in the tennessee house
sponsored by state senator mark podey
and state rep jerry
sexton it quote permits a person to
petition a court for an injunction to
prohibit a woman who is pregnant with
the person's unborn child
from obtaining an abortion we've been
told by the left
men cannot have an opinion about
abortion squishy republicans say this
too
men should not have an opinion this is a
woman's issue it only involves a woman's
body of course that's not true
it involves a baby and that baby by the
way is not just the product of a woman
it's a product of the love between a man
and a woman
it's not just the woman's child that she
would be killing but
the man's child too so i i
sort of would offer the exact opposite
advice that we hear from the left which
is
a man should have no opinion about
abortion i i think a man
should absolutely be able to prohibit an
abortion
if we still have legal abortion which is
unfortunate at the very least the father
should be able to stop a woman from
killing
his child this is very democratic
how is this democratic there's no
one there's no constitutional right to
an abortion there was
an invented fictitional fictitious
constitutional right
from roe versus wade that even honest
liberal jurists will admit is nowhere in
the constitution
when you ask the constitutional scholars
you say where is it in the constitution
you find that right
they'll say well it's in the emanations
in the penumbras
in between an invisible link between
lines 35 and 36 i
okay i don't really i don't see that in
there of course the constitution doesn't
say anything about abortion
the only thing it maybe could say about
abortion actually is the 14th amendment
which would prohibit abortion right if
by protecting people equal
equal protection but
the question broadly has been left up to
democratic processes you persuade your
fellow citizens okay
we should have abortion legal abortion
or we should not have legal abortion or
we should permit this kind of abortion
okay well that's what's going on in the
tennessee legislature right now
certainly it would be it's democratic to
allow a man
to have a say over the future of his
child
in addition to the woman adding that say
would would be
an increase in democracy would it not
or you have the alternative which is
some robed lawyer on a court invents a
right
and takes away your political freedom to
make a law
now i i hope conservatives get behind
this bill
one because it's pro-democracy or
whatever i just want to show that
ilhanomar is a hypocrite
but also because this is this is
offering some real substance here
oh you're pro-life okay good
then prove it put up or shut up
i i think most of the pro-life activists
probably all pro-life activists would
support it but i i want republicans even
who are moderate on this issue i want
them to get behind this there is no
reason whatsoever
that this bill should not pass in
tennessee
and as the states are laboratories of
democracy no reason why this shouldn't
be tried out elsewhere in the country
we need to stop playing on the terms of
the left we need to stop allowing them
to say well it's a woman's issue well
it's kind of touchy well i don't know
it's a third rail i don't want to touch
it
no touch it head on if we're not willing
to say that
you shouldn't kill children and if we do
have a system where you can kill
children at least the dad should be able
to stop it
if we're not willing to say that we're
not willing to say anything
and the left there they've already won
and we should just roll over you know
that they're promising to persecute
conservatives right now
not just trump at all of us they're
promised i mean the congressmen are
saying this out loud
media figures are saying this out loud
if we're not willing to stand up for
ourselves then let's get it let's have
it be done with
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you